Bon dia! Diumenge, dia 4 d'octubre, dia 309 de la volta al món a peu, aquí a la sortida del meu hotel.
Mireu quines vistes. Aquí tenim el Hunza Peak i l'Ultra Peak.
I a aquesta banda d'allà tenim el Diran. Crec que es diu el Diràs.
Totes elles, muntanyes de 7.000 metres i super nevades. Avui cap núvol. Guapíssim.
Bé, anem a visitar avui Hunza i els diferents poblets que formen aquesta vall, diferents fortaleses.
Potser tenim un guia local, però primer de tot anem a esmorzar.
Esmorzar fet abans de pujar fins al TIT, que és l'objectiu d'avui.
Recordeu que això estava tancat? Doncs mira, avui està obert.
És l'antic assentament de Garnix.
Aquí, o sigui, aquest lloc va ser el primer assentament de la ruta de la seda de tota aquesta regió.
El primer cop que va estar poblat. I és de fa mil anys. Mil anys fa això, que està poblat.
I la mesquita aquesta, que és tan maca, doncs no és tan antiga. És de fa 700 anys, la mesquita.
Per què no és originària de quan es va crear l'assentament?
Doncs perquè l'islam no va arribar fins a aquesta zona del Paquistà.
Fins al segle XV, al 1400 i pico.
A les altres regions del Paquistà va arribar molt abans l'islam, però aquesta regió no tant, és més nou.
Bueno, faré una volteta per aquí, que m'ha costat 3 euros l'entrada.
I us ensenyaré algunes fotos. Veig que hi ha nens, no sé si la gent viu aquí.
Hi ha nens.
Clarament aquí hi viu gent i et cobren entrada per entrar i poder caminar pels carrers de la ciutat antiga, per dir-ho així, on viu la gent.
És una mica violent perquè, clar, jo vull fer fotos, vídeos, perquè m'agrada l'entrada, però a la vegada és com...
És un safari, saps? És un sol.
Però bueno, mola, eh? Mola bastant.
Em sento una mica incòmode. Potser me'n vaig, eh? Ja he vist prou.
Ostres, mira que xulo això, eh?
Hola a tu. Mira, mira.
Ui, que caic.
Mira aquí, eh? Déu-n'hi-do.
Ojo que no em vingui una nena i m'empenti.
Fa!
Molt bé, ja estem aquí al fort del Tit, amb l'Islam.
Islam, sí.
You're going to show me a little bit around.
Beautiful, eh?
Magnífic el lloc i les vistes.
Ara estic veient el que vaig veure ahir des de baix, eh?
Normalment, a la volta del món a peu, com que caminem molt per baix, sempre veiem les coses des d'una perspectiva baixa, però ara, des d'aquí dalt, doncs també mola bastant, eh?
Bueno, vindrà un guia ara i ens explicarà alguna cosa, així que a veure si puc reproduir el que m'expliqui i us recordo i us expliqui a vosaltres.
Bona nit.
La Vall de Hunza.
La Vall de Hunza, un lloc perdut entre muntanyes que durant segles va ser un petit regne independent situat a un dels corredors més estratègics del Karakorum.
Just per aquí, on porto caminant aquests dies, passaven les rutes que anaven des del subcontinent indi fins a ser central, Uzbekistan, Tajikistan, etc.
D'aquella època, ara fa 1.000 anys, queden restes espectaculars, com aquesta, el fort del Tit.
aquesta, el fort del Tit,
la residència dels
reis de Hunza, que s'anomenaven
Mir, la família Mir.
A pesar que aquesta vall
és molt petita, els Mir tenien
molt poder, perquè el pas per aquestes
muntanyes era tan complicat
que molts cops només es podia fer a peu
i això els donava molt control sobre el
trànsit. I no eren precisament gent pacífica,
no. Havien fet ràties i
invasions al costat xinès, a la
part de Xinjiang. Aquesta columna
que veieu aquí és una tomba
on s'hi va enterrar algú en vertical
a dins. Si ens remuntem
als inicis de tots, la vall
de Hunza va ser habitada primer
per tibetans. En aquesta
vall em comenten avui que hi viuen
més de 35 ètnies
diferents. I com us he dit
abans, l'Islam no va arribar fins
fa 400 anys. Abans
d'això va haver-hi altres religions,
com per exemple el budisme.
Aquí ara veurem un símbol
que té una càrrega
actualment molt negativa, que
és l'esbàstica, que
els nazis la van copiar
dels pobles aries d'Iran
i Índia. I és un símbol
que està tant al budisme
com a l'hinduisme. Tot això, però,
va acabar el 1891,
quan Hunza es va
trobar enmig de dos grans
imperis. 140 anys abans
arriben els britànics al subcontinent
indi i comencen la seva
expansió. Tenien una
obsessió en que l'imperi rus
no s'expandís cap al sud,
i per contrarrestar això, van anar
tirant cap amunt, cap amunt, fins que
van arribar aquí, a Hunza. I així
aleshores es va acabar la història
d'aquest petit dregne independent.
Els britànics ja no van continuar més enllà,
no van invadir mai
ni Xinjiang, ni Afganistan,
però sí que van pressionar els afganessos
perquè fessin el
corredor de Wuhan, una franja
estreta que permetia que l'imperi rus
no es toqués en cap cas amb
l'imperi britànic. Més tard,
el 1947, els britànics
van abandonar la regió
i es va crear l'estat de Paquistan.
La vall de Hunza es van
accionar al nou estat, però
va mantenir durant 30 anys
la sobirania. I fins aquí
de moment la breu història de Paquistan
i d'aquesta vall. Aquí
el guia, que era un crac, em diu
no et moguis, i comença a córrer i a donar
voltes per la taula d'aquesta. I jo,
què està fent? Doncs això, això estava fent.
Aquí es duien a terme les execucions
al regne de Hunza, simplement agafaven
la gent i la tiraven cap per vall.
Després de la interessant visita, anem a fer
un cafè al bar
d'un amic de l'Islam. I després
m'intenta regalar aquesta gorra,
cosa que agraeixo molt, però li dic
home, no, perquè això, què faig?
No puc portar la motxilla, saps?
Més sorpreses. Aquesta casa,
la casa més antiga del poble,
no, sinó el fet
que aquí, en aquest lloc,
hi van ser l'aleshores
príncep Carles i la seva
esposa, ara rei Carles.
Següent parada, menjar
i beguda locals. Let's go.
Bueno, m'han portat aquest cafè tan
tan maco. Aquí
al cafè Hunza, estem amb
el Salman, que m'ha portat
també aquí uns dumplings de
chicken, chicken dumplings, eh?
I un suc
de raïm, d'aquests raïms que hi ha
aquí a sobre. Vull dir, més orgànic que
impossible. Molt bé.
I recommend, I recommend people
to come to this café, yes.
So, Islam is a teacher
here. Yeah. Can you
show us a little bit the typical
instruments from Hunza?
Sure. So, we have
traditional antique
instruments. So, this is called
xarda. Xarda.
This is the Tajiki instrument,
pamiri rubab, you can say.
It looks very old. Yeah.
Almost more than 100 years.
Wow. So, we have
a daf.
Yeah, yeah, it's daf.
It's also the Persian instrument, I think.
This is the cetrali setar.
Setar means three strings.
These two.
It's also old.
And this is more like modern, I guess, right?
Yeah, yeah, this is the rubab. Rubab?
Actual rubab, yeah. This is a funny rubab.
This is the one that we saw the
old man before playing, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes.
So, this is a star in process.
A modifying star.
I'm working on it.
Oh, you also make instruments. Yeah, yeah.
So, we have another instrument
I will show you.
It's called jagani.
It's a bowing instrument.
Wow. Sounds like a violin, yeah.
Yeah.
And he is the founder of this jagani.
Hashim Shah, my grandfather.
Oh. Yeah, his grandfather.
You come from a musician family, yeah? Yeah, yeah.
Also your brother. Brother, yeah.
Yeah.
So, we have made the coffee.
Well, the tea, in this case.
Hello.
Some pastas.
Very good. And we have already left the island.
The truth is that I didn't know
very well what I could expect.
Maybe it was ten minutes to make a coffee and say
hello and that's it.
And in the end it has been about five hours
because it's three o'clock.
So, very good. I have learned a lot.
A lot of things.
It's been very good.
Now I will go to the other fort.
There are two forts in Hunza.
What we have seen and the Baltic Fort.
Well, I will look from the outside.
And then I will walk
about eight kilometers
to the end of Hunza, the end of everything.
So, tomorrow morning,
it's already there, it's at the end of the village,
I will start my way
to the base camp of this mountain.
Brutal, aquest fort. Molt l'única, la seva arquitectura.
La paret aquesta de color veig, amb aquests pilars de fusta.
I el que és més brutal d'aquí són les vistes, tio.
No, no, a les imatges no ho veureu tant
perquè està una mica a contrallum, vale?
Però la muntanya aquesta blanca, tots els arbres verds, el riu blau.
Jo sabia que Pakistan, el nord, era maco, però està superant.
Totes les meves expectatives, eh?
Totes les meves expectatives, és increïble, és increïble.
Partit de futbol set aquí a Hunza.
Saps el poble aquí, eh?
Bueno, just ara quan baixava
he passat per davant de l'oficina de tíquets.
Cap pujant no l'he vist.
I he entrat sense el tíquet, tu.
Val? Doncs camino ara els vuit quilòmetres fins a...
Bueno, vuit, set, la veritat és que no he agafat cap lloc encara.
Buscaré què hi ha.
Parlem-hi?
Passo.
No es pot trastecar.
Sí que no.
Potser ja en tenim un darrer.
Potser sí.
Acabem de veure.
Sí.
Ahí, aquí.
Sí, aquí.
És un punt.
Doncs hem de fer una altra cara.
De tota la gent, AP, som a l'aigua.
I us donem la llum del разгój, que ja t'enten baseu.
Sí.
Això està explicat.
Aquí.
I bo, és un punt.
No, jo parlava amb la parella.
No.
Jo vaig anar a veure qui agafava el baló per aquí.
Els títols.
Ja tinc hotel. Avui 3.000 rupis, que són 10 euros, un pèl més car.
Com que no s'ha acabat el dia, vaig a intentar tallar-me el cabell.
No me'l vaig tallar a la Xina, que vaig tenir temps de sobres i podria haver-ho fet,
perquè no me'n refio de l'estil xinès capilar, saps?
Jo veig els paquistanis i el seu tall de cabell s'assembla més al meu.
Hi havia algú al bar. Bé, m'ha dit que esperi 25 minuts.
Bé, mentrestant he vingut a un restaurant. És d'hora encara, són les 6.30, però bé, ja sopo.
He demanat d'alt, que són aquestes genties, aquest típic estofat,
i el que m'han portat és un petit plat de dalt.
I un munt de pa, tio, però un munt de pa, eh?
Bueno, està bé, tinc gana.
Què? M'han deixat bé o no?
Jo diria que sí, eh?
No molt curt, està bé.
El tio és un artista, eh? Si ha estat una bona estona allà amb les tisores.
Jo és que esplugues en tallava el cabell a un paquistanès.
I ho feia molt bé.
I de fet, des que me'n vaig de les plugues, que vaig a Terrassa i ara estic fent aquest viatge,
l'home encara pregunta per mi, i es dís la mà bata, es veu.
Bueno, l'habitació està molt bé, tu, no? Una mica així, modern i tot.
M'han dit que em podré dutxar ara, no m'he d'esperar a demà al matí.
I sabeu com m'ha costat el pagui de cabell? 80 cèntims.
I el sopar? Això que us he dit, oh, massa pa, tal, un euro, brutal.
Vinga, anem a fer resum, deixo el mòbil aquí.
Doncs avui ha sigut un dia més aviat cultural.
No tant caminar, he fet 17 quilòmetres.
M'he gastat 22 euros.
I això que no m'han deixat pagar el dinar, ni el suc aquell, ni res.
Moltíssimes gràcies a l'Islam.
Molt bon guia i molt encantat d'haver-te conegut si estàs mirant aquest vídeo.
I bueno, l'hotel i tot plegat, això. 22 euros.
Dos tests, cap refresc i avui he parlat amb tres persones.
Dia molt estrany.
O sigui, sensacions estranyes, saps?
Perquè no estic acostumat a la volta al món a peu a fer aquest tipus de coses,
de quedar amb gent, tal.
Porto quatre dies a hotel, a no caminar tant.
Ho estic gaudint moltíssim.
Aquests dies de Pakistan m'estan encantant.
Però sensació estranya.
Bueno, ja tornarem a caminar.
El trekking aquest del camp base pot veure's interromput o he de mirar
perquè diu que dimarts, avui és diumenge,
per tant ha passat, pot ploure.
Tempesta elèctrica i dóna bastanta possibilitat.
Demà miraré la previsió amb més exactitud perquè, clar,
és que pujar fins al camp base d'una muntanya,
si ha de fer aquest mal temps, ja veuríem, no?
Ja veurem què faig.
Avui mola destacar la gent, eh?
La gent que he parlat avui és gent molt culta.
L'Islam fa...
És professor de música i, de fet, la llengua aquesta que tenen ells,
el...
M'ho ha dit 40 vegades i no me'n recordo.
Aquesta llengua, doncs, no té forma escrita,
però ell està agafant les cançons tradicionals d'aquesta llengua
i l'està passant a forma escrita amb alfabet urdu, en aquest cas, no?
Alfabet àrab.
Sí, sí, ho està fent això com a pioner, que no ho ha fet mai ningú.
Ho està fent ell, dona classes, tal.
I després també he parlat amb un amic seu que treballa a Dinamarca
a la farmacèutica.
La farmacèutica que fa l'Osempic,
una de les farmacèutiques més grans del món.
I, bueno, treballa allà.
Vull dir, gent molt culta.
M'he trobat avui.
Després, no sé si us heu adonat,
que potser tenia el llavi, la part de dalt, una mica inflada.
És que ahir estava intentant agafar el nòrdic
i tirant-lo cap així i no acabava de...
Estava molt dur i en una d'aquestes he fet
se'm rellisca la mà del nòrdic
i toco contra la boca.
I res.
Ara sang aquí.
No ho veureu.
No és res, eh?
Però sí que tinc aquest llavi una mica inflat.
I res, doncs demà segueixo caminant.
Ara sí.
Però el repte de demà serà aconseguir diners.
Perquè he anat en aquests quatre dies
a cinc o sis caixers
i tots em denegaven la targeta.
I es veu que no és...
És algo habitual, eh?
Que potser tinc problemes.
A veure com ho fem.
Bona nit.